the United States Navy SEALs by the US
Navy's primary special operations force
and a component of the Naval Special
Warfare command the seals main functions
are conducting small unit special
operation missions in maritime jungle
urban Arctic mountain and desert
environments the seals are tasked with
surveilling capturing or killing of
high-priority targets and gathering
intelligence behind enemy lines on enemy
forces the Navy SEALs trace their roots
back to world war ii the United States
military recognized the need for the
covert reconnaissance of landing beaches
and coastal defenses as a result the
joint army Marine Corps and Navy and
fibia scout and Raider school was
established in 1942 at Fort Pierce
Florida the scouts and Raiders were
formed in September of that year just
nine months after the attack on Pearl
Harbor from the observer group a joint
US Army Marine Navy unit there was a
recognized need for unconventional
warfare and special operations to be
used as a measure against guerrilla
warfare in Southeast Asia in 1961 the
government announced their intention to
spend over a hundred million dollars to
strengthen the u.s. special operations
forces and expand American capabilities
and unconventional warfare the Navy
needed to stamp its role within the
Special Operations arena and in 1962 the
Navy SEALs were born before getting
accepted into basic SEAL training a
candidate must pass a certain number of
both mental and physical requirements
these tests include medical screening
and the seal physical test after the
reactivation of team rainbow in 2015 two
Navy SEAL operators who recruited to
bring their skills and expertise to
assist in the fight against terrorism on
a global scale these operators are named
Blackbeard and Valkyrie
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
how do you write with you
[Music]
freak Jensen codenamed Blackbeard is an
attacking operator and team rainbow
Blackbeard has always had a taste for
adventure and it just five years old
one night he told the families camping
equipment outside and set himself up in
the woods behind his house do you remain
there for two days
only deciding to return so his parents
wouldn't worried that he was missing
later he learned that they had known
exactly where he was the whole time and
regretted not staying away longer as he
felt most himself when surrounded by
nature it was around this time the black
bear decided that he wanted to become a
Navy SEAL he would be the first in his
family to deviate away from the
speciality of the medical sciences and
as he thought to break from the family's
traditions and devote his life to
achieving his goal at the age of twelve
he joined the Boy Scouts along with the
United States Navy SEAL Cadet Corps his
father who was a professor at the
University of Washington encouraged him
wholeheartedly to pursue his dreams his
desire to see the world and serve his
country was further solidified so at the
age of eighteen he enlisted in the u.s.
Navy joining the military offered him
the ideal opportunity to pursue an
academic education while learning a wide
range of skills that fueled his
adventurous spirit
eventually he succeeded in his ultimate
goal of joining the US Navy SEALs and
even worked as a seal instructor where
he met Valkyrie during her hell week
training the drive and disciplined scene
in seal team members is what drew
Blackbeard to the organization to him
seals exhibit the ideal blend of
physical and mental abilities and he
strives to develop these attributes in
himself he is athletic rugged and
competitive and it's important to him to
succeed in both his professional and
private life Blackbeard is client when
Mount Everest sailed around the world on
several occasions and participated in
the u.s. sailing championships he
believes the wilderness builds tolerance
willpower and acceptance and encourages
adaptation
black beard says he shares the same
passion as his great-grandfather to
explore the world although unlike his
great-grandfather who quit his job one
day and went north to be a gold miner
he's not interested in abandoning his
family for his own selfish exploits he
considers himself to be a family man and
win at home he often enjoys playing
pirate games with his children in 2016
he was recruited into rainbow and is a
reliable operator with a commanding
presence and a clear image of his role
he's very successful at it and
well-liked by his team who enjoy his
boisterous sense of humor and booming
laugh Blackbeard utilizes a ballistic
shield that attaches to his rifle the
tars mark zero transparent armored rifle
shield as a prototype based on the
armored shield technology for tank
Gunners it allows Blackbeard to increase
his mobile protection without
diminishing his field of vision
confirmation visual on the target
activating camera
tango in my sense
Megan Castellano codenamed Valkyrie is a
defending operator and team rainbow
Valkyrie has been fortunate and growing
up with two highly respected individuals
within their chosen fields born and
raised in a small surf community in
California her mother is a researcher
for a local biotech company and if
either is a colonel in the Marine Corps
she has always been a high achiever at
school especially in maths and science
so being top of the class and the go-to
person comes naturally to her an
exceptional swimmer and once an Olympic
hopeful for the 200-meter breaststroke
the South leduc Wonder child enjoyed
splitting her time between the pool in
the army base unfortunately at the age
of 16 she broke her arm in a car
accident and her Olympic ambitions were
owned this paid with the completion of
her high school studies meant that she
had come to a crossroads and decided to
enlist in the Navy in the early 2000s
she initially served for four years
before attending college upon completion
she graduated with a degree in computer
science where she specialized in
security and cryptography she later
transferred to the Navy's information
dominance Corps with their work and
information and counterintelligence was
used to support the US Navy when the
opportunity to train to become a seal
was finally granted to woman Valkyrie
immediately applied and it was during
this time and more importantly during
Holy Week as she made an instructor by
the name of Blackbeard the training was
grueling and for the first time in her
life she was surrounded by a number of
high achievers like herself which was
something she was not accustomed to hell
week five and a half days of cold wet
brutally difficult operational training
and fewer than four hours sleep it is
physical endurance mental toughness pain
and cold tolerance teamwork attitude and
the ability to perform work and a high
physical and mental stress and sleep
deprivation above all it is
determination and desire
finally after several years of strenuous
training Valkyrie succeeded in becoming
a Navy SEAL and her actions in turn
motivated other woman to follow in her
footsteps in 2007 Valkyrie acted as a
seal Intel source for Grom operator Ella
in operation orange sky through their
collaboration L was able to spend her a
number of months infiltrating a warlords
in a circle before dismantling his
Network entirely and all without harming
a single civilian her analytical skills
and attention to detail make her one of
the most sought-after specialists and in
2016 she accepted an offer to join
rainbow alongside Blackbeard she is
aggressive driven and exceptionally
focused and will do whatever it takes to
accomplish the mission in the most
seamless and effective way possible she
often feels intimidated when surrounded
by other brilliant minds even those
within a team and although she respects
Blackbeard there is no great fondness
between them in 2019 team rainbow lost
contact with kuvira as she had gone off
the grid Valkyrie and twitch go on a
search and find that she is in Bolivia
with the help of the ghosts twitch works
alongside while Valkyrie guides them
from HQ after twitching the ghosts
investigate a crash truck they find out
that kuvira is searching for a man in
the cartel as twitching the ghosts
looked through the man's apartment they
find out that the cartel member is an
undercover Brazilian police officer and
kuvira's brother the team links up with
kuvira at the chemical Institute and
together they find and rescue Caviar's
brother and extract him while the
mission was a success it caused tensions
to rise between her and kuvira
valkyries gadget is the black eye Geyer
came back to the black eye is a quick
deployment sticky camera that is encased
at an attempted silicon ball photo to
micro suction cups the suction cups
allow the camera to stick to almost any
surface while the gyroscope mounted lens
stabilizes the camera angle and focus
once deployed the live video feed can be
viewed from all defending operators in
the same manner if there's normal
cameras these cameras have a wider field
of view capable of rotating 360 degrees
when placed on the ground and can look
around faster than normal cameras I'm
not sure when this happened but the
profile of the SEALs team was finally
updated and gave us a little more to
read about on top of this the jtf2 team
has been updated so it should have this
one out soon - thank you very much for
watching I hope you've enjoyed yet
another indian story time Cheers
you